of top eight qualifiers we're going to
have tachi kala from Japan versus Wolof
and youth France itself this is a really
exciting one so this is the other EU
player that we could still see in our
top eight voila
definitely favored to make it while with
just one was it eg w GX e GX I believe
out there and the EU and it was quite it
was quite a celebration over there when
he won so I'm sure everyone from home is
watching right now getting excited for a
Wawa but I'm also really excited for
talked to Carlo - still not be out yet
Tachi kala coming all the way from Japan
mostly other Japanese players probably
sitting on a decent amount of points
right now this really needed to come out
to this one especially with Red Bull
Japan coming up and Red Bull Spain so
big chances to get points there matachi
tawa try to get every point he can
possibly get right so he's here in porto
rico at first attack get the powerup
candy going real quick yeah I think he's
had a little bit of trouble the last
couple events here I think especially
finding a team that worked again for him
because you know he was like kind of the
hipster player at first you know playing
hit Frieza and Android 18 for a while at
the comic break here we saw that and
evolved to now what is his team dropping
all three of those carry them all on the
injured reserve
he's a brought to the starting lineup
the team going on the GT Goku and the
Yamcha he's definitely looking to win at
the character select screen however his
signature character Frieza was the
character that sent him to losers at the
helm of Chris G I think that's Karma a
little bit I think that's Karma
or maybe Chris she found all seven
dragonballs and his Frieza used them to
wish himself a little bit taller
yeah and that was the advantage that he
had on him Chris holler Frieza
maybe his Frieza was taller than talk to
Thomas Frieza I mean but being tall and
this games not good that's true maybe
maybe a trunk maybe he shrunk himself
just to like be like GT Goku size just
couldn't see it only it shrunk his
hitbox that we could see all right we
got Wawa coming up here though let's
talk about wala so you know obviously a
connoisseur
you know base Goku right yeah I mean I
think I've drank my fires in general
right he played so many members in the
cast at egx we saw him play some Gogeta
what is this team was a button check
team from tachi cow right here the
karela majin buu in the Videl I mean
maybe he's just gonna show us some
Crillon tech that we have never seen
here maybe it's some special rock throws
I was about to say cuz the Wawa does
have a lot of the castle under his belt
right like I said we've seen him play so
many teams of course his main businesses
main chicken is what I think we're gonna
get right now yeah his go on is really
good too I really do love seeing us go
on the one thing that I didn't agree
with yesterday that was in the game that
he sent got sent to losers with was he
switched from his go on after doing it
was not yelled at sent up to two losers
and the one thing I didn't agree with
was he got rid of go on and switched in
Bardock and it in his barn oka just
exploded yeah it was weird because he
didn't really lose the first game by
much so his go on was doing a good job
there was no need for it honestly yeah
man we're seeing the adult Gohan back in
action up against Hachi cow was in his
first game and yeah well what just in
general I think it's been one of the
most inspiring Dragonball Fighters
players in 2019 he's just brought
incredible tech to the table in general
his decision-making and adjustments are
out of this world again I'm very
surprised to see him in losers top eight
qualifying match it's definitely I think
if there was any upsets of the of this
tournament so far that is definitely one
of the bigger ones yeah
the only thing is that wah wah did
loosen Akio last year at UFA so knocking
out does have his number besides that I
think just with how much of an overall
favorite wah wah was it is indeed an
upset for a second alright caller being
very respectful he was facing trying to
make his move in though throwing out
these key black bagger enough yeah but
these players know that tournament life
is on the line here right so no one's
trying to make any reckless maneuvers
but he's not gonna have a chance to use
it just yet talk to power points the hit
are we gonna see a snap out we are the
character to bring in here and get rid
of as fast as you can which he is
already big quick work of is that based
okay yeah it's gonna be the character
talking I was at least matchup
experienced against is one of the most
deadly characters in Wawa's hands now
he's gonna play the snap meta force him
to play one character at a time and
we're gonna spark up super dad though
not a good place for wala to be sitting
that especially after using that
sparking it's running out exactly he's
gonna be able to get him down here you
another snap out and sparking did
nothing to get wha-wha out of this
defensible bet some that - part of
hesitated and then got that to em hey
brazen GG Goku here - to end this oh man
he is dead no more face goku for wall
wall we got the level 3 Spirit Bomb I
said I was gonna follow it up no dragon
rush necessary he's gonna play it nice
and safe all the way through number one
and that is a dead base Goku voila being
very make quick work of here by tachi
column that locks the Kristy's Frieza
really set the fire here for touch
column nice car cancel the legs allah
tryna get some offense momentum back
here that was staggering the streams
I like that and it's not something that
you're gonna expect talk to cover to you
because you don't really see MVP that
much devices reversals but usually like
the level three right not really the
deep even teen gohan another overhead
open up a lot of meat are being built
yet but dead Gohan if you can please the
column bunny most definitely will dragon
rush DP into the level one just needs
one more to finish it just like that
touchy Paulo barely touched right now a
little bit help take it away from his
team going on but that is it is this
thing on sparking wah-wah it's a danger
here of losing this first game that was
a signal extension yatra piracy pushing
the opponent away o punishes the whip
reflect with the dragon flash pissed all
right I like the guard canceled out of
the corner on the spot there with that
ear hair gonna get hit by the Gohan oh
my god yeah the two harnesses caught on
that he converts off of it that means
that wawas go to his bed and touching
overwhelmingly takes the first game he
is hungry for those points I don't know
what was in that candy that he ate but
he is powered up he was a bulldog Wawa
that game is all over him maybe it's
gone maybe he's trying on gum yeah I
mean he's still chewing so that's either
a Hardy candy or something you know
maybe secret Japanese tech that we have
not seen yet with candy yeah I know I
know super news always trying to be on
the latest latest hip tech to what the
Japanese players are doing outside of
the game like the the speed reading that
go Ichi does the the eye drops the
Rosie's the Candy's I still don't know
about those eye drops
I heard it's literally like putting mint
in your eyes and I go bad them I cannot
fathom that Rindge
it's like you know the feel of like
brushing your teeth that's how it feels
on your eyes but it burns a little bit
more I don't like that in 1080p to 4k
what you want ahead but but what if
there's lag 4k TVs have a lot of loud
not when you take the road Aziz you
think Bowie she's gonna get sponsored by
someone would lag never that you know
maybe go eat jesus that god like it
doesn't matter that's fair that's true
he is that God line he is a God I came
to now magic Howard did took the first
way we got Wawa switching to the cell
right we saw him switch his character
after losing the first game yesterday
but man hopefully this cell does more
work in the Bardock we want to see while
in right now especially for those who
are fans of Wawa gets hit by that
unfortunate started notice because you
don't have to deal with the fuzzy setups
on the incoming but man he already
snapped them out nice dragon rush techno
all are gonna get a chance to play with
his baseball yeah we need that Wallace
special there three bars already built
crazy let me your heads number one spear
ball a long tries to counter the of our
cancel while the elbow coming through
and the crowd is going wild over to
baseball who is so entertaining man nice
smart go from top to cow it doesn't want
to take any more of this pressure it's
wild to because when this character came
out everyone was complaining at first
they were like another go through but it
is the very exciting go through they did
a really great job of making them unique
absolutely problems going right back
into it while although late on a
punishment I agree with the sparking
here cell in the corner of my place we
want to beat great use of the sparking
with the bandage to get that hit I was
beautiful holding the mash getting that
on the other side now the solo
Kamehameha with a long knock down to
knock down right into that level 3 Oh
got caught back that thing with that
truck tags me huh all right
snapping in basecoat who knows his
character is a problem you try getting
with a hesitation to em again but
wah-wah more discipline this time that
punishes the whip reflect to Edmunds own
I don't love it here we go it's ending
with the beam going right into the pie
okay beautiful here takes them towards
the corner Stokes the uptake you're
gonna stay on the ground I'm going to
command bro you and this is gonna be I
believe enough yeah do the energy field
you got this
voila coming back from that first game
looking better with this so once he gets
cooking on that base goku man's hard to
stop them you know yeah I think it's all
debates Goku really like celebratin all
but while I'll face go through yeah we
we hey that's definitely what was
cooking in this game too
yeah jumping over now hochy Cowell was a
solo Yamcha I mean we've seen him come
back with his character before nice
perfect attack punished doesn't have a
sparking but still a big damage starter
and he has to at this on deck if he can
accept this
here we go hug them hug it out boys
Oprah yeah too much hits done on that to
actually get the command or afterwards
oh I love the defense here and the great
reflect off of that we're trying for the
Aged for a big attack attack token for a
little bit of damage but he's trying to
give his base Goku done wins
okay great texture from wah-wah base
Goku playing offense right into the
dragon rush to wall are you maniac
yeah Sachi Cowell was looking for the -
OS right there right he - directly into
the arms usually the dancer was you
press the button lay enough to actually
get the tech on the dragon rush but not
successful touch column that time it is
one up here in our last match to see who
completes our top page he was doing so
much working that he was making Sachi
Cowell a competent
yes brush the bullet gain the power from
it a people rate you know if he braided
it he might have like a like Jedi powers
I was gonna say yeah that's a mean Jedi
rats alright yeah you know speaking of
Rockhill he does like dirty on his team
so channeling it but he's gonna find
that hit below yeah while waking up with
some stuffed mushrooms perfect attack or
a lion either way gets counted brushing
the mullet seemed to do a good job here
cuz he's already coming into this first
game strong with the snap he really was
his base go through said they'll break
block on the low up to the legs on the
since punishes the liver pluck pillars
of the to elbow right so wah-wah
could have been a bit more yeah
I thought all I had at their cue but
tatcha caller delayed that next pitch
yeah he was going to be forced into a
fuzzy situation there so Wawa is using
the Spartan to bypass that but he
completes the conversion off the GT go
to assist yeah that GT consistent while
I arrived kochak I was ready for it -
it's got this level three off now and
wallah goes run up in the dragon rush
it's gonna be a dead cell no sparking
down to two characters this is not a
good game three so far for Wawa and no
Dan and I need to talk to colors life
bars either dragon rush tech again and
the reactions of the young man walk walk
the elbow yet again how you been to
himself off the go to assist oh he's
right through it and again that's
something that you're gonna be
conditioned not to really expect the
Topsy call because he doesn't really oh
he gives me it falling mix up again on
wawas base Goku here he's got enough
here to kill him off you just gotta
finish the combo and he thaws three make
sure he's dead make sure that GT Goku's
on point for this last character as well
Wow well was that all the reader in the
world but no other characters no
sparking topic I was super healthy and
the town of the 2f opener with a super -
super - is that's what something I just
don't expect to Perimeter but it's
working and it gets that overhead
whooping the dragon flash this and then
air - while he was falling to get that
mix-up great stuff level three again
just trying to widdle this life bar down
on Wawa not caring if he gives up the
corner he just wants those hard and
knock down all try to go back to the
original side doesn't get in that Wawa
has a window of opportunity
all right Walmart's trying to do what he
can sell with what he has left not a lot
of health left
at least he's using some of these bars
yeah like that he's gonna bash in out of
the corner so the level three put them
back in the corner which goes in the
jump medium some staggers here almost
got a head did not really commit to it
goes into the dragon rush this is gonna
be a dead GG go to Utley so one
character left for him not to have to
worry about here perfectly calculated by
wall or the last hit killing off the DT
goes only one meter spins gonna have to
be scary this is the character that I
think really get rid of here for Wallace
you can get rid of teen gohan somehow I
can't believe they're just finishes the
job beautiful stuff toxic I was sneaking
in that instant air - teen Gohan is so
fast they can combo off of it with the
legs and he does so Tasha kama makes top
eight and wah-wah the person I
considered the favorite to take the
entire tournament Falls one game short
of top a I think we only have one eu8
rmz made it from a UK who I mean no
disrespect to our MZ but I'm sure shanks
and wah-wah or more favorited to make
the top Ethan he shout out to him that's
gonna like you know he's already on the
map and he's been on the map but this is
like you know really big for him and I
think this is really big to tachikoma
taking that I think Taj acaba really
needed those points really needed those
points he needs the points and he needs
just I think the morale like boost from
these w's Breithaupt Chicago has been
having a lot of struggles you can see
him dancing over there so Big Ups to him